he's the aforementioned jon hamm who
joins us on the program John how are you
this morning how are you sir I'm
spectacular where are you today I am in
sunny Los Angeles oh if the Sun is out
today as opposed to the last pilot they
were it broken for like a week and they
and they finally figured it out they're
like alright turn the Sun back on whoops
what happens what are you here on the
street when you when you're walking
around let's say you're in New York what
what is the common question or comment
that you get stop yelling at me about my
taxes
I like those commercials no I actually
do too I was very pleased with how that
came out and that's obviously only a
very recent one mostly people it depends
upon what the season is if it's baseball
season somebody will usually say
something terrible about the Cardinals
to me it's a that's usually what I get
do you get Mad Men comment and if you do
what time yes I do and mostly very very
pleasant people people like to that show
so I was happy that they did because
that made me have a job for almost a
decade what did you drink on that show
um water with food coloring usually you
know and meaning sometimes it was teeny
would depend upon who the prop guy was
that week usually the we had one guy
prop guy who was like kind of like a mad
scientist he had a very specific kind of
it's got to be three drops of this and
one drop of that to make it the perfect
color and the old-fashioned had to have
the fake cherry and of this I mean it
was longer this one guy was very
particular which I actually appreciated
it was it's always nice to see something
that bigs their job do Keith Osso suits
I didn't keep any of those suits because
first of all there's there's a good
reason that
we live in the 2010 and a big part of
that is light fabrics they were made of
like 2-inch thick wool because they're
all vintage they're all you know pulled
from like real that and it was funny
because I would see sometimes they're
pulled from this huge costume shop up in
Burbank called Western costume that
basically has all of the costumes from
Hollywood from forever so every now and
again you'd look in a in a suit pocket
and it would say like Burt Lancaster or
something in there and then whoa yeah it
was kind of me
John's part of the NHL 100 primetime TV
special that'll be friday on NB NB C's
carrying the all-star game now I know
you're a Cardinal fan are you helping a
hockey fan are you I'm a massive hockey
fan I mean it's uh it's interesting that
the Blues have been in the I'm from st.
Louis if it wasn't painfully obvious
already the Blues are it's their 50th
anniversary of being a franchise and I'm
45 years old would be 46 this year so
I've been around almost as long as the
Blues have and and we've had some
tantalizingly close brushes with almost
greatness for a few of my formative
years so I've been a Blue Sam for a long
time I've been a hockey fan for a long
time I never really played because I
never really could skate I mean I could
skate a little bit but that's that's not
good enough but I've just been a massive
fan of the game I think it's uh
I love the the you know it's got a it's
got everything that the that a cool
sport should have it's a passionate fan
base
you know it's wildly fast and furious
and it's and in the way that it's played
and it's got this kind of specific
arcane kind of weirdness to it too so I
love it how do you think they got Paul
Newman to play the lead role in slap
shot when you think about how big Paul
Newman is buzz can you imagine reading
that script
that's hilarious and Paul Newman was you
know Paul is a hockey fan the
connecticut guy
he probably played like prep school
hockey or something I don't know but
like he uh he wanted to do it I
guarantee you that it's a bit the bigger
question is how did they get a studio to
make that movie because that is they
that is a very specific fanbase but I'm
glad they did because that's that's a
that's a classic and I'm looking at your
first acting job do you remember your
first acting John here are you looking
according to IMDB yes
now here's those here's how its credit I
wouldn't have any idea what they would
put the first one on us what does it say
Ally McBeal
it says glue gorgeous guy at bar
compromising positions 1997 uncredited
gorgeous guy at bar well do you ever get
for that I do actually because when I
first got to LA I was an extra three
times I was an extra in a commercial in
a movie and in a TV show and the TV show
that they pulled me out of line they
were like hey come here the director
wants to see you and I was like and and
so the guy goes hey we need we just got
to cut to a guy at the bar and we have
to ask you if we can hold the camera on
you for more than a second that makes
you more than an extra makes you a
featured extra and would you be okay
with that and I'm like yeah sure
whatever I have no idea what's going on
and and that was what that was but nice
yeah I was very very pleased to get the
extra $75 that it man yeah I cleared
this up was there a run-in with Bill
Murray after Game five of the World
Series story starting to get traction
yes it is yes there was and in the best
possible way because the Cubs in one
game five I had been there in Chicago
for three and four and five and
as you may know mr. buck is a friend of
mine and he was calling all of the games
for the big Network and I got to go he
said come meet us over at the the place
next to the stadium and I was there by
myself I was watching the game by myself
so I said ok I will and I met him over
there and the usual suspects are there
and the Murray boys are and girls there
the whole Murray family was there and
and Billie grabbed my hat and threw it
over the wall into the alley and so I
had to go through a door and pick up my
hat out of the alleyway and put it back
on and walk back into the party it was
very funny alright here's my question
for you and I've been sitting on this
one and I'm not really sure what your
answer is gonna be so you can have an
Academy Award or you can get rid of the
Cubs winning the World Series oh look
I'm not that I'm not that kind of sports
fan in the sense of I I don't really
hate other teams I'm a passionate
believer in my team I just I can't must
muster it up to hate another team I was
I was like most of America glued to the
edge of my seat on Game seven of that
World Series I thought it was one of the
best world game sevens of any sport that
I've ever seen has a game seven and I
was thrilled when they won you know I
mean look III I want I want every fan
base to have and then maybe this sounds
like kind of gloating because I've I've
seen my team one of the few times in my
lifetime but I wish every fan every fan
base could could win it at least once
because it feels so good you know and
especially in baseball we talk about a
162 game season and how long that how
long a run that is and how capricious
and and and weird the luck can be in in
the postseason and all those things have
to break the right way and you have to
maintain focus for so long like it's
just not only bad I don't root bad for
anybody
so and by the way yes I would much
rather have an academy work for myself
okay
absolutely more selfish than me being
gracious
is there a hockey guy that you haven't
met they Yelp to meet um that's a good
question I haven't met a lot of them I
have met some of the some of the big
ones Wayne Gretzky's wife Janet actually
grew up one kind of town next to me in
st. Louis she's from a very interesting
little Township called and I'm not
kidding
cool Valley so she was I was in Belle
Reve acres and she was in cool Valley
and we didn't know each other growing up
but but we we've met since since then on
several occasions and Wayne has always
been incredibly nice as a fella and and
I mean I've known him for now for almost
15 years I put in the golf tournament
with him a long time ago and watched his
kids grow up and their bits unbelievable
so I met him a few times and I know
Brett Hall a little bit from st. Louis
and Shanahan as well I've known him
through the years I got to hang out with
him at the Olympics in 2010 so I know a
lot of the guys and I'm looking forward
to to meeting them but mostly I'm
looking forward to to participating in
this and and helping them celebrate
because it really is a cool achievement
to be around this long and and and I
like how the NHL does its business for
the most part it's a very it's a very
well-run organization and you know it's
kind of it's kind of a weird time for
sports leagues these days and that
there's not a lot of love out there for
them and in many cases that's very well
earned and having been the having been
the beneficiary of NFL franchise leaving
my home city twice mmm it's it's there's
not a lot of love for certain way
certain people run their business but
the NHL I've always I've always thought
has a has some kind of a different more
sort of stable and approachable
way of doing it and I don't know I love
it every time I said anybody that I've
ever sent to a hockey game a
professional hockey game has come out of
it with a giant smile on their face like
that was the coolest thing I've ever
done especially British people they find
it they find it fascinating for some
reason have fun on Friday night we hope
to get you into a B or one of these days
and good luck and thanks for joining us
as always John
my pleasure Dan thanks very much all
right jon hamm the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]